如果是把我换成是你的话，
我可能会先要一个证，
因为要一个证，
将来我才有更大的选择的空间，
有了这个证了之后，
我将来如果说我遇到一个他是喜欢女的，
我觉得也挺合适的，
那我可以再婚，
我可以再谈恋爱，
这个就不受拘束。
我和我老公自由恋爱结婚，
今年马上10年了，
我们有一个6岁的女孩儿，
我今年35岁，
我是四年前发现他出车，
出车的对象是男生，
她在外面下载男童交友软件，
很男的约会聊骚，
频繁的去同浴室，
这么多年备胎怀孕什么之类的，
我都没有上班，
都是靠她在养着，
那时候孩子还小，
所以我选择没有离婚。
这么多年来说她对我真的很好，
是一个好爸爸，
好老公，
对孩子也很好，
就是对我的照顾是无微不至，
别人眼中模范的丈夫，
模范的爸爸，
包括像剪脚指甲呀，
给我吹头发呀，
洗衣做饭带娃，
她样样都做，
挣的钱虽然不交给我，
但是家里的所有开销都是她。
我自从发现他这个事情之后，
我就开始想办法养活自己，
现在有一份收入只够养活自己，
也攒了一点小金库。
最近又发现他还是戒不掉，
频繁的去浴室去泡澡，
在想我要不要跟他扯用，
还是继续这样得过且过。
爸妈是干啥的，
我父母是个体，
但是给我没有什么帮衬，
因为我娘家还有个哥哥，
她爷爷在带我的侄子，
另外我的公公婆婆特别好，
据我老公说，
他应该不是纯统，
她可能是双偏童一点，
她也是后期被人家掰弯的，
你四年前就发现了他喜欢男的，
这四年当中你们还过正常的夫妻生活吗？
过这方面基本上都是他主豆，
而且也很照顾我这方面的感受，
那他是一对不对，
他在男的，
他说他是0.5，
他从来都没有承认过他跟人家发生过什么接触之类的，
0.5是可攻可守，
是这个意思吗？
对对对，
是这个意思，
但是他没有承过，
他到现在都不承认，
她吃同，
因为之前就是疫情期间，
她压力很大，
她说她对那些男的都是利用什么之类的，
我不知道是真的是假的，
他还没给我块过夫妻生活，
而且这也很照顾我的感受，
而且夫妻生活上都是她主动对，
我现在也不知道他到底是什么样子的，
而且他这两年就是每次给我爱，
比如说一冷他，
或者是发生争执的时候，
他就爱去泡澡，
去浴室，
一年可能去了10次8次这样子，
我最近查手机就发现的，
我那女人现在使用安全，
四年前发现之后我会每三个月让他去查传染四项，
我们全部都做安全测试，
包括也不接吻，
安全方面我会比较注意。
我现在在纠结我要不要去扯重，
因为我又舍不得。
他因为对我是真的很照顾，
对孩子也很照顾，
现在小孩上学街坊都是他，
挣钱也是他，
家务也是他做，
就包括现在我们我发现他又去泡澡之后，
我扇了他几巴掌之后，
最近我们不是已经登记了嘛，
这个期间也没有给我解释什么，
就我不相信她回避和我一块沟通这个问题，
就是说只是单纯的去身体不舒服想去汉中泡澡什么之类的，
那你当初发现她男生确实是有证据显示她约男生确实是有这个那方面的行为呢？
还是时不实锤吧，
你当初发现了，
就我是通过微信账单发现了他跟人快520那种转账记录，
以及他下载男交友软件，
以及去同性浴视的这个账单转账记录什么之类都有，
算是实锤吧，
那对孩子你有什么想法呀？
因为现在我们的协议上是这样写的，
他的婚前房产，
我们各自婚前房产都归他，
他的房产就是到时候孩子成年之后过户给小孩儿，
我有居住权，
住在他的这个房子里，
等于说我们现在达成协议可能是离婚不离家，
还是住在一起共同养育孩子，
孩子抚养钱给他，
我不用出赡养费，
就等于说以后可能就是我自己挣钱养我自己，
他就是挣钱养孩子，
养家供房子什么的，
因为他的收入说实话不稳定，
他是自己做装修设计的嘛，
你们年的房贷每个月加车贷就要1万多块钱，
他的收支可能刚好就够这些，
可能还多余一点，
这样子我现在纠结的件是我事之后在他那。
一点都捞不到了，
就是什么都得不到了什么之类的，
但是日常上他还是肯定会照顾我的，
这个我呢，
我确定的是你觉得你对他还有感情吗？
我对他我也不知道，
反正依赖肯定是有的，
但是你发现他这些我心里肯定也是难过的，
现在很复杂，
现在就很纠结要不要去扯这个种，
就现在主动权在我，
我不扯呢，
就是这样子，
感觉像是自由式的婚姻似的，
扯了之后呢，
我可能更自由点，
他不会管我去，
比如说真的遇到喜欢人，
在恋爱里他应该不会管我，
也不会再去查他的手机，
查他在在那有再约其他人，
你现在是等于是冷静期是吧？
对，
大概要等多久，
还有10来20天左右，
我觉得你应该先在这个时间的话，
把你的住权这个事情落实一下，
我落实了，
我去查了，
问了他，
现在有房贷，
银行不同意出去同意还，
所以我就办不了居住权，
房贷大概多久能还完，
起码得20年吧，
那有没有这种你们签一个居住权的协议去做公证的这样一个途径呢？
我离婚协议里写了我有终身居住权，
这个公证的有用吗？
因为银行那边不同意，
我不知道有没有法律效应啊，
就算公证了，
银行不同意是基于对他自己利益的考量，
但是公证处能不能办这个事情呢？
我认为是有空间的，
因为公证处他也是自负盈亏嘛，
自负盈亏就是说公证处他也不是铁板一块的，
是这么个意思。
其实严格来讲呢，
从物权这个角度来讲呢，
没有。
房还贷款的房子办居住权确实是有障碍，
因为一旦办了居住权，
就意味着这个房子想卖都卖不掉，
就是就是想买房子的人看到这个房子里面有居住权就意味着什么，
意味着虽然我买了这个房子，
这个房子归我，
但是我赶不走这个居住权人对我知道肯定是有障碍的，
但是如果你的居住权实现不了，
他要给你一个什么样的违约赔偿，
我认为这个是可以公证的，
嗯，
对，
我签了合同，
如果比如说他违约，
比如说赔付50万，
赔付给小孩100万，
这样的，
我开会已经达成共识，
写在合约里了，
就写在协议里了，
对对对，
我的理解就是说在没有还完贷款的房子里面去给你社区住权，
这个没有办法公证，
但是在没有还完贷款的房子里面去约定你可以居住，
如果你居住不了了，
给你一个经济的补偿，
这个是有空间的，
嗯，
这个我已经写带协议，
那您是建议我就这样过着，
还是说我就给他会先去领这个证，
就是领了之后我们还是在同一个屋檐下，
查到之后，
我们现在不是已经分房睡了吗？
如果是把我换成是你的话，
我可能会先要一个证，
因为要一个证将来我才有更大的选择的空间，
有了这个证了之后，
我将来如果说我遇到一个他是喜欢你，
我觉得也挺合适的，
那我可以再婚，
我可以再谈恋爱，
这个就不受拘束，
但因为我现在的经济条件是。
我自己的经济条件一般，
父母也帮衬不上忙，
我又想跟孩子生活在一起，
那我就去判断一下，
领了这个证了之后，
他的行为态度会不会有重大的转变，
他会不会赶我走，
会不会不让我见孩子，
如果说他不会赶我走，
也不会不让我见孩子的话，
如果是我的话，
我愿意先拿到一个证，
给我自己一个选择的权利，
明白明白，
我感觉的是，
他肯定是不会赶我，
阿姨，
谁的脸小了，
我有居住吗？
比如说赶我走，
或者房子卖掉，
他赔我违约金，
这样子，
那就是我听你的建议，
现在去吧，
就拿了我，
让我也是这样，
而且你和他之间不要再有这个亲密的行为了，
保证你自己的安全，
好的好的，
他提出的意思是，
那我们对一家，
比如说双方父母那边就先瞒着，
比如说他父亲拿过寿，
让我陪他过去一起演戏干啥的，
这些要配合段时间的，
这个都没啥说，
除了两个，
其他一切照旧是这样的意思是吗？
不要有亲密行为，
你自己该撒摸一下你的未来，
你未来应该是去哪里呀，
干什么呀，
找什么对象啊，
你现在就开始考虑自己的将来了，
如果这一次真的领了争是我打，
那以后可能也是不结婚，
不会再生孩子了，
还是为了这个小孩吧，
有时候真的遇到喜欢的，
可能就谈谈恋爱，
这样子那也挺好的呀。
我一直纠结的就是我现在挣的只够我自己花，
扯了证之后，
他那边就比如说现在开店的支出啊，
包括什么，
他就不会。
给我支付了，
唯一让我有点割舍不掉的就是这个，
但是长远来看的话，
还是对自己来说的话，
是身体健康，
命活着最重要。
就这几年其实我一直在反复陷入到情绪反复或者干嘛的，
我不知道到底是不是就是这个问题，
这个答案我可能没有人知道，
就只有他自己知道，
你作为旁观人，
包括直播间的姐妹就是他，
这种到底算不算呢？
我自己都很纠结，
很累的，
这个我们作为外人是没有办法给你下这个判断的，
是你自己跟他相处的过程当中，
你自己去感受，
如果他不是喜欢男生，
那么他在你发现他当时的那些可疑的迹象的时候，
他就有更多的证据来举证自己了，
但他没有好的，
好的就是我的协议里面就关于房子的那个，
这个预告登记我是不是也要把他弄进去，
因为我怕到时候他万一比如他真是说他要遇到喜欢的女的，
他家里逼着他再结婚，
再生小孩，
房子不给我家的女儿，
我现在就协议里面现在可以再加个预告登记之类的嘛，
就是说比如房贷还境的时候，
到时候在90天过户给我女儿这样预告登记这个事情，
像你现在的状况，
能不能去做这个预告登记这个因为我确实很长时间没有办过预告登记的实物了，
我不敢确定，
如果能办的话，
那你就去做啊，
还有就是因为他现在他这个房子是婚前的房子，
但是装修是我装的，
我出了30万装的。
这个协议里该怎么写，
更多的保障我的利益什么之类的，
那你也可以白纸黑字的写清楚，
你当时装修这个房子花了多少钱，
在这种情况下，
他愿意签字，
就表示他也认可你花了这个钱，
就如果将来出现他背着你把这个房子卖掉了，
处理掉了，
抵押掉了，
或者干嘛了，
没有兑现承诺的话，
那么他应该这30万作为赔偿也好，
作为偿还也好，
补偿也好，
应该给你是不是啊？
也就是说你出了30万，
如果将来他把这个房子给孩子的话，
你就觉得这是心甘情愿的，
但是你出了30万装修，
如果将来他把这个房子卖掉了的话，
那30万块钱你要退给我，
或者补偿给我，
这个也可以写清楚，
好的好的，
如果孩子抚养权给他，
我共同抚养，
比如丽现在在同一城事又不离家，
这样一约定，
会不会以后有什么累点或者什么之类的呀？
其实抚养权给他了之后，
哪一点就在于他拥有一项权利，
这个权利就是不需要你的同意，
他可以带着孩子去另外一个城市去生活，
甚至带着孩子去别的地方去工作呀，
搬家了呀，
因为协议里写了，
我说不能把孩子带走，
包括送回老家或交给别人抚养，
必须在南京，
这样就是抚养上学，
是不是我协议里写的这个有法律效应吗？
有一定的约束力，
我之所以把孩子给你，
是希望孩子。
能够有更好的教育，
有父亲的陪伴，
如果你把孩子给老人，
你把孩子甩到农村去，
那就违背了我把孩子给你的初衷，
这个在法律上的话，
你这样约定的话，
是有一定的约束力的，
好的好的好，
谢谢老姐，
暂时没啥问题了，
好，
就这样啊，
好的好，
拜拜，
记得点赞关注哦。